we have five different games and five
hundred dollars whenever somebody beats
us they win 100 and we move on to the
next challenge first up the roundabouts
racket I'll set the score to beat and if
you can beat it you get a hundred
dollars so one two three four five okay
five you have to get six okay one two
one try
one
no
okay that's awesome go for it ready yeah
one two
thanks have a good day have a good day
hey guys if you can bounce the ball more
times than me you win a hundred dollars
oh what happens if not nothing one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven and yeah
three four five six seven
you want to try okay
one two
oh
that's possible so if you get three you
win a hundred dollars Perfect all right
sounds good all right no pressure no
pressure oh my God
[Music]
we're gonna continue until someone can
beat me a challenges mini pin pong one
rally if you win that rally you win 100
oh my gosh
we'll see you
oh
whoa
okay bye okay walking down the main
street
just to do here yeah
oh
that was intense
one point one five dollars
too small man it's it's very small yeah
oh it's yeah
[Music]
you too
have a good day
for you if you win one point you get one
hundred dollars one hundred dollars yeah
one point you get to served
[Music]
there's one hundred dollars thank you
congrats congrats you have amazing
serves yeah that's all let's move to the
next shop time for Peter Paul
let's go okay so you know the rules
oh
[Music]
we should definitely not do this
challenge in the U.S I'll subscribe
right now and guys if you haven't
subscribed to pongfinity yet now is a
good time to do that
[Music]
somebody gets more advances than us
today with 100 two three four so we'll
see it's not that easy
here
boy a good try thanks for the try we
will have a little challenge for you
one two three four four okay
um
that's 100 for winning the challenge
nice congrats guys
remember to subscribe okay so far we've
managed to gank two new subscribers but
if all of you guys watching subscribe
now we might reach our goal of 5 million
a bit faster so sure hit the ping pong
Club
first one to knock it off wins I feel
bad I feel like I might hit it don't
worry don't worry oh that was that was
close
so that's why I said don't don't worry
about Kitty
shout out to Joe's cocky no you survived
the first runner I did I did however you
want
oh let's try it
let's try not that one if you can knock
the cup of his head you win a hundred
dollars
foreign
[Music]
no problem
still have to go hard I'm just gonna
place the cop here you go for it
walk the gloves
yeah they're good technique there
I didn't see that coming at all you
gotta try hey I'm so sorry don't worry
about it oh bits High
clothes
oh
[Applause]
you guys are awesome you can win hundred
dollars if you can get more bounces than
me with this racket okay okay one two
three four
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
okay yo shout out everyone bro shut up
one two three
thank you good try one two three four
five
very good it's more bounce all you gotta
do is beat me one two three four oh four
four bounces one two three
uh here we have our friends again if you
get more bounces than me you win a
hundred dollars
[Music]
rebound says if you can do it you win a
hundred dollars you'll be the first one
today to beat me one two three
yes you got it I found a winner wow here
you go
a hundred dollars
congratulations